this morning in our series pushing the
limits we revisit a father and son's
inspiring journey to some of the
toughest Triathlon courses in the world
we introduced you to Jeff and Johnny
agar in November seven months later lead
National correspondent David bagno
reunited with the dynamic duo ahead of
Father's Day to pull off an incredibly
special surprise
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for coming glad we didn't scare
off too much
there's no chance Johnny agar we fell in
love with the agar family when we first
met them last November is there a better
man than your dad I've yet to find one
for me for a story about Jeff and Johnny
father and son triathletes
29 year old Johnny was born with
Cerebral Palsy
there you go that a boy it is a muscle
disorder that makes it impossible for
him to walk without assistance
[Music]
there you go
but with the help of his hero Johnny has
paved his way in the most unlikely of
sports it's one that Jeff takes on for
both of them I believe
when he bikes he hauls him
when he swims he pulls Johnny
when he runs he pushes him mom's cooking
when we get home Jeff told us back in
November for his son it's all worth it I
mean I'm not a fan of swimming biking or
running so which is perfect for
triathlon so this probably wouldn't be
in the top hundred things I would select
to do I'm not doing it because I love it
it wasn't like a dream of mine this is
Johnny's dream I'm just giving him the
legs and the power to do it it has
become Johnny's passion
to him and his father to Iron Man races
those are the toughest of endurance
events
team agar has a 2.4 mile swim
a 112 mile bike
and a 26.2 mile run and they have to
finish it all in under 17 hours
about why even try it you may be
wondering to prove what Iron Man's
Mantra is
anything is
now look they failed the first five
times they tried to finish an Iron Man
in the time allowed but on the sixth
attempt they did it
[Applause]
cross that finish line
[Music]
that Victory last September inspired
Johnny's dream to one day cross the
finish line at what is considered to be
the Super Bowl of triathlons
the Iron Man World Championship in Kona
Hawaii now teams like the agars need to
be invited to compete and guess what
Iron Man wants to extend that offer for
a team they say personifies the spirit
of the sport and they decided to let us
break the news
so we planned a trip back to Michigan
but we told him it was furry Father's
Day surprise so in the time since we
first met to today have you had any new
epiphanies any new aha moments you know
maybe a question I asked that you long
after I were gone were like here's one I
thought any anything the uh the feedback
on social media is a bit overwhelming I
find the things that hit me the hardest
is that people will comment that you
know I don't do anything with my kids
and here's this guy doing this and I
should be able to do so much more I hope
that just inspires fathers to believe
you can do more you have to be a great
father you just have to do better than
you are today this is the
to put in the way to be able to get me
across the finish line
really inspires me now in the spirit of
Our Father's Day theme I asked the agars
to record a message for all the dads out
there hello America we're the agar
family I'm Jeff I'm Johnny Becky Annie
and I'm Gracie and we want to miss All
fathers a Happy Father's Day
nailed it on one okay do you feel good
about that yeah can we watch it back by
the way ready ready for this moment we
got a Little Help From A Hall of Fame
quarterback who happens to be one of
Johnny's favorite athletes hey agar
family Peyton Manning here listen rumor
has it you're a big fan of mine I really
appreciate that that means a lot but I'm
a big fan of yours as well you guys are
incredible you're a true inspiration now
I've heard there's a big dream that
you're hoping to achieve together well
while we make that dream come true right
now on behalf of Iron Man it is my honor
to share with you that team agar has
earned an official invite to the 2024
Iron Man World Championship in total
Hawaii congratulations good luck and
I'll be rooting for you the whole way
uh
oh
[Applause]
my gosh
it is toasty warm out today starting now
team agar has 16 months to beef up their
training for the world championship an
Iron Man sent us their official ticket
to KOA there we go Johnny
energy
that I
I I have gonna be really really
special for me
thank you so much
Johnny and Jeff they have what no other
triathlete in this sport has when they
compete
happy values day thank you
I love you I love you too bud
oh my God David talk about pushing the
limits try not to cry try not to tear up
with that playing and you nailed that
that surprise the misdirection the form
of the Father's Day theme I mean take me
into the room with you what was that
like
Tony don't tempt me with the good
surprise man it was an absolute joy and
I'll tell you I feel optimistic this
morning so I'll say this when they cross
the finish line in Hawaii in the time
allowed they will be only the third team
in Iron Man's nearly 50-year history to
cross the finish line at the world
championship
so unbelievably gorgeous this is why I
don't watch David Beckner pieces in
public
ugly cry David thank you so much we
really appreciate it we'll be rooting
them on